let's get the news out of Washington
where President Trump is leaning on
fellow Republicans to push back against
impeachment and his allies in Congress
seem to be listening dozens of members
delayed a hearing yesterday storming
into a high-security room where another
official was due to answer questions
about the White House lobbying effort in
Ukraine Democrats called it a stunt to
deflect attention from earlier damaging
testimony by a top US diplomat the
president lashed out again at Republican
critics calling so-called never Trump
hers quote human scum and quote Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where the
drama was unfolding yesterday Nancy good
morning so what were those Republicans
looking for Joni they want the
transcripts of these depositions to be
made public so they can read them they
want future depositions to be held out
in the open
Democrats say that's not how
investigations work here on Capitol Hill
or anywhere else and they've already
scheduled several more closed-door
interviews over the next week we want to
know what's going on about three dozen
House Republicans tried to crash the
deposition of Pentagon official Laura
Cooper but they only succeeded in
delaying it by about five hours what are
they trying to hide from the American
people that they won't allow voting
members of Congress to hear what's going
on in that room Cooper was the ninth
person to be interviewed behind closed
doors as part of the impeachment inquiry
I cannot access witnesses I cannot even
read their testimony if a government can
do this to the President of the United
States they can do it to you as well you
need to be scared
Democrats scoffed I'm not really sure I
guess when you're desperate you go back
to complaining about the process about a
quarter of all House Republicans sit on
the three committees currently involved
in the impeachment inquiry several of
them joined in the protest members have
had it even though they're already
allowed to attend the depositions and
ask questions
Democrats accused the GOP rebels of a
blatant breach of security for taking
their phones into a secure room
our Republican colleagues evidently have
freaked out because they have nothing
substantive to say about that we believe
that this needs to be transparent and
open when she finally was able to
testify Cooper backed up what others
have said about the unusual nature of
the holdup in aid to Ukraine Democrats
contend that closed-door hearings are
necessary for investigations and cited
both the Clinton and Nixon impeachment
proceedings which included closed-door
interviews investigations are not public
when the investigation is done there'll
be public hearings that's how it's
always been done if the house does vote
to impeach this we'll all head to a
trial in the Senate after ambassador
bill Taylor's testimony were number two
Republican there had this to say about
the picture coming out of it based on
the reporting that we've seen is
I would say is
not a good one a very candid assessment
from a top Republican John Thune though
he too complained about the process and
said that without full transparency it's
very difficult for anyone to get the
full picture Tony and Nancy we're now
learning that Ukraine's president held a
meeting with advisors before he was
sworn in and this was apparently to
discuss how to deal with requests from
the president's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani why might this be important and
what else do we know it's important
because this meeting took place two
months before that now infamous phone
call between President Trump and
presidents and Lansky where President
Trump asked him point-blank in July to
investigate Vice President Joe Biden and
his son so Lansky met with his top
advisors to discuss how to deal with the
pressure that they were getting from
Giuliani and others to dig up political
dirt the Ukrainians wanted to avoid
getting caught up in a US election this
meeting reportedly lasted almost three
hours and according to the AP zalenski
cited a congratulatory phone call with
President Trump as the source of his
unease the contents of that phone call
Tony
still have not been released all right
Nancy Nancy Cordes for us on Capitol
Hill Nancy thank you